you never know
where we're gonna find tom curran it
could be on the golf course it could be
out behind his house it could be parked
on the side of the road scaring the crap
out of us as semi's whizzed by here he
is in his normal habitat the studio at
nbc sports boston hello tom how are you
it's been a while
this is great i don't understand why you
shut me off but apparently my number has
come up again i couldn't be happier
about it
well i shut you off because the team you
cover stinks
can't disagree on that mike and i'm not
seeing rebounds
the next thing to go will be the annual
florio christmas card you can take him
off
take him off
it's been a very eventful though 20
years for the new england patriots and
it and the dynasty was born in a weird
sort of way 19 years ago today the tuck
rule game the last game at foxborough
stadium
the first thing that that you remember
about that night
just the visual
of it
knowing this was the last game that was
going to be played in foxborough stadium
knowing everything that the franchise
had been through knowing that they were
playing the hated raiders who
really probably short-circuited the best
team in patriots history prior
to that year's team in 76
so you go in there and the lights you
know bright white lights are hitting on
mounds of snow and you're looking and
you're like they haven't done anything
to the field they're gonna play on this
stuff
it really felt like like we were in a
snow globe and it was a celebratory mood
in so many ways you just can't
imagine a better
scenario to close down the stadium and
then everything that followed
i'm told that after the fumble or at
least what everyone thought was a fumble
the fans began to stream for the exits
and then actually they were let back in
once they heard walt coleman's voice
over the pa system where were you when
all that was happening press blocks
first row i was writing at the time for
the metro west daily news
uh suburban paper and framing ems
circulation about 35 000. so i was
sitting right there and uh watched it
and you know
i obviously as we all did thought fumble
and the one aspect of it too and there's
a little background noise here hopefully
it stops here in the studio
um but the one interesting thing about
it was
the replay you never see brady's other
hand touch the ball you can presume that
it did and i asked him in the post game
said tom did your hand ever touch the
ball again and he was wearing a scally
cap and the patriots used to have their
post game press conferences in that
stadium in the weight room brady's like
no i don't think it did just kind of
smiling um
but yeah my perspective was right there
in that front row of the press box
yeah and you know nobody really knew
what the tuck rule was although it had
kind of been percolating in recent games
or had been a game earlier that year
where kurt warner did something like
that and it was impacted and actually
had been reduced to writing just the
year or two before the 99 season i think
it was that it ended up in the rule book
and of course it lasted another 10 years
or so before it was wiped out they
weren't going to take that one off the
books
too soon otherwise it would have
legitimized the complaints from the
raiders but that was really something
and now let's pivot to today here we are
19 years later tom brady in his first
year with the team other than the
patriots on the brink of a super bowl
and tom of all the great things that tom
brady's done or that anyone in sport has
ever done the idea that he's now at a 90
success rate getting to the final four
over the last 10 years is incredible to
me
i think one of the most amazing aspects
of it too mike is when you look at the
quarterback feel for everything that
brady does
in high leverage situations and we're
talking about this today on some of our
shows when you match up the four guys
remaining brady has the weakest arm
he's got the least mobility
he wins on brain
poise situational awareness 18 for 33
for 199 people are saying that's not
really a very good game
he didn't turn it over he cashed in
every turnover with a touchdown
when you look at the list of guys who
played pat mahomes couldn't patrick
mahomes couldn't finish
his playoff game
last week lamar jackson same thing alex
smith couldn't make the start jared goff
has surgery we've seen aaron rodgers
laid low by calf injuries brady just
keeps answering the bell year after year
after year the guy who was supposed to
succeed him here jimmy garoppolo can't
stay healthy in san francisco that to me
mike is the one thing about brady that
when bill belichick decided he was going
to push away from the table he didn't
take into consideration enough
40 43 45 the guy doesn't miss games
it really is amazing the presence of
mind that he has in the pocket the
ability to get rid of the football not
take the big hit the ability to to step
up and there there was a moment at one
point this season where he moved up in
the pocket as the walls were caving in
around as the defensive ends collapsed
it that way it almost looked like a
madden glitch it was a jump cut that's
how quickly he moved up in the pocket to
deliver the football he's got that sixth
sense he knows how much time he has and
and you're right he answers the belt but
for the 2008 season where he took the
low hit from bernard pollard who's out
for the year with the torn acl he just
keeps going and that is such an
underrated aspect of valuing a
quarterback can he play every week and
you know you mentioned the the the
numbers down near 50 percent even as the
completion percentage shrinks all the
other numbers go up the yards per
attempt go up the yards per completion
against washington where were 17
per completion he's getting the ball
down the field like bruce arians
envisioned when he joined the team but
the reason they won last week is because
he said screw this i'm going to throw it
to leonard fournette
and that's the reason they won in those
games against um new orleans that they
lost they came out mike and immediately
said okay we're gonna try and throw it
and that wasn't really the way to go
because they went three and out three
and out three now brady still needs
to be accurate into small windows with
guys who aren't really accustomed to
playing with them so you do have to be a
diverse team you do have to be able to
do it both ways and i think that who
which of the quarterbacks has the most
answer this mic which of the
quarterbacks of the final three have the
most pressure on him to play a seamless
error-free game to get them to the super
bowl i think it's brady
because that todd bowles defense as well
as it performed in all the takeaways
that it had it had four guys chasing the
wrong guy alvin kamara
on the the double pass that winston
threw a touchdown pass there were two
near punt return touchdowns there is no
margin for error for the bucks
yeah that's a great point now the bucks
defense woke up in a very stunning way
in the second half as it looked like the
saints were going to go up 23 to 13 or
27-13 when antoine winfield ripped the
ball out of jared cook's clutches and it
changed after that but you just don't
show up
confident that your defense is going to
be doing that you do need something from
the offense and brady's been getting it
done what are the folks up there saying
about the scoreboard for the post brady
belichick relationship is it one nothing
brady based upon what we've seen so far
yeah it's one nothing and the scoreboard
watchers are out in force
you know people like me who said that
you know the reason the patriots were
not a scintillating team offensively in
either 18 or 19 wasn't because of
brady's declining skills but the fact
that he really had no one to throw to
feels somewhat vindicated the guy's 43's
got 40 touchdown passes but i think a
lot of people are saying look
if the patriots wanted to pivot
and they are doing so bill belichick was
60 million and as you pointed out today
maybe even more than that in cap space
coming up
don't render him
not
a factor going forward yet to me mike
it's very simple if bill belichick
doesn't have the conceivable answer for
at quarterback before tom brady retires
at 45
then it was an absolute beat down and a
terrible mistake to move away from him
end of story and it's already headed
that way
when belichick watches brady play in
these playoffs where do you think he
lands on the scale and and let me just
come up with a rough
uh positive and negative on one end he'd
be wearing a brady tampa bay buck's
jersey on the other end he'd have a tom
brady voodoo doll where does he land on
that spectrum
i would say it's probably a daughter two
away from the voodoo doll he's not
holding it
he's not holding it but he's he's online
scrolling trying to find where he got
one delivered fast yeah i was talking to
a friend of mine today i said what are
the odds that he just calls up rex
burkett and said look i know you got the
bad knee but is there any shot that you
can get down to tampa this week and just
run into brady's right hand and try and
tear that open again like you did a
couple years ago
that's wrong imagine if he goes and
beats green bay it's two weeks of bill
screwed up
no he's gonna have to have a voodoo doll
michael
yeah uh and what patriots fans though
are they supporting tom brady in the
second act or are they are they uh
anti-tommy
i think it's more tampa bay is good for
me and i'm enjoying the hell out of it
but the very vocal
f that guy he left
group is certainly well hurt as well
um you know we
get it as we cover brady like a team
unto himself here at nbc sports boston
why are you covering brady he doesn't
play here anymore well because it gets
clicks um
but i think that
more than anything
there's just the sentiment of
look he was a part of the 20 years mike
and i mean if you're in the media let's
be honest
am i talking to you do i have the job i
have do i have this wonderful 188 dollar
suit jacket
and a job in the media had i not been
lucky enough to cover the belichick
brady patriots i don't know but i'm
lucky i was i i want to see the guy do
well
it's i mean is that am i forfeiting all
journalistic credibility whatever amount
i still have left if i say i want the
guy to do
well first of all you paid too much for
the jacket and second of all he's in the
most non-threatening spot for the
patriots he's not in their conference
and they're not in the playoffs it's not
like they're on a collision course for
the super bowl the patriots are done
it's over so if you want to be invested
in the post season and you still have
warm memories of what tom brady did
you you you support him now in his time
as the quarterback of the tampa bay
buccaneers because it doesn't diminish
anything he did with the patriots even
if he wins another super bowl right
well that i think really because there
are as many belichick files as there are
brady files and every time brady does
something that defiles the belichick
files and bill belichick is diminished
then those people who
are belichick loyalists come out with
the bayonets sharpened and we saw that
this week i can't remember who
tweeted it was chris gasper from the
boston globe tweeted um
brady playoff wins without belichick too
belichick wins without brady playoff
wins without brady won
and
people were went berserk but facts is
facts and maybe brady's a carpetbagger
and bill's
transition back to being
a playoff coach is going to be harder
than toms where he could just parachute
in
but it's thought like bill isn't part of
the reason the team is a little bit
bereft of talent and completely hosed if
josh mcdaniels takes the philadelphia
eagles job
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports